you are looking at the demographic
breakdown of China and India's
populations in 1990 both countries
demographics resembled a pyramid which
meant that there were far more young
people being born than there were old
people but fast forward to projections
for 2050 and you'll notice a dramatic
change the Chinese pyramid Narrows to
resemble a shape more like a funnel
for more than two centuries China has
had the largest population in the world
this year the UN said India will take
its place India's population is expected
to keep growing for the next four
decades peaking at nearly 1.7 billion in
2063 China's population is projected to
shrink rapidly by the start of the next
Century India's population is expected
to be double that of China's all the
signs point to a very challenging future
for China demographically here's why
this shift marks a watershed moment for
both Nations and what the change could
mean for the global economy
this year China announced its first
population decline since 1961. in 2020
China's fertility rate or the number of
children a woman has over her lifetime
came in at 1.3 which is one of the
lowest in the world the roots of China's
demographic crisis can be found in its
one child policy the policy was designed
to keep birth low so that China would
have the opportunity to grow its economy
it turns out in reality the one child
policy has far more long-lasting impacts
than policy makers intended in a way it
worked too well starting in 1980 most
Chinese couples were strictly limited to
one child despite reversing the one
child policy in 2016 China's fertility
rate has continued to decline the
replacement rate needed to keep a
population stable is 2.1 meaning that a
woman would need to give birth to least
two children to keep the population
stable and essentially replace the
parents with a fertility rate of 2.0
India's fertility rate is slightly lower
than the replacement rate the reason why
India's population is projected to keep
growing for several more decades is
because India unlike China still has a
fairly large group of women of
reproductive age that's very different
from China in China the one child policy
produced a dramatic gender imbalance
that originated in strong cultural and
social preferences for male children in
2021 the number of marriage
registrations plummeted to 7.6 million
the lower since the government started
keeping records in the mid-1980s
the global economy has grown to rely on
China's vast pool of factory workers for
manufactured goods and its consumers
represent a growing market for
western-made cars and luxury goods a
declining Chinese population would mean
that there will be fewer workers to make
products that are exported to other
countries and there will be fewer
consumers especially younger consumers
to buy goods from other countries
in the coming decades demographers
expect China will face a huge worker to
retiree Gap in 2020 14 of China's
population was over 64 years old while
in India just seven percent of people
were over 64. by 2070 nearly 59 of
people in China will be over the age of
64. while in India only 30 percent of
the population will be in the same age
bracket a larger group of retirees will
mean that younger Chinese people will
have a bigger of a burden to support the
elderly that's especially true in the
rural areas in some ways India looks
like China did 30 years ago it has a
rapidly expanding working age population
with 610 million people under age 25 and
relatively few older people to care for
India's Rising population means it's
likely to keep its economy growing buy
more of the world's goods and play a
bigger role in global Affairs but
India's rise isn't insured in this
problem now is all about jobs yes it
does have a large working age population
but at the same time it is struggling to
create jobs for its young people India
is primarily a rural nation and still
lags behind China in urbanization unlike
China where millions of Migrant laborers
move to cities to work in factories many
Indians are reluctant to leave their
home towns India also significantly lags
behind China in terms of female labor
participation India's cultural norms
have meant that families who can't
afford to keep their daughters and wives
at home prefer to do so when Mao took
power he really pushed the idea that
women is equal to men for a long time
China's women labor participation rate
has been very high and for India that
seemed to be not the case whatever
happens the world's future population
will be tilted more towards the global
South and South Asia in particular in
2060 the three successor states to
pre-independence India will have 2.3
billion people versus China's 1.2
billion guaranteeing profound changes to
the global economy
foreign
[Music]